if it's about saving lives and
protecting the nhs a major part of the
omicron response depends on whether it
is indeed milder than the delta strain
and today the first evidence from uk
hospitals that it is a major study from
scotland estimates a 56 reduction in the
risk of hospitalization there with
omicron compared to delta researchers in
london looking at english data came up
with a similar number those with omicron
40 to 45 less likely to spend a night or
more in hospital compared to delta
infections
overall people were 15 to 20 percent
less likely to go to hospital at all
with omicron in england
definitely good news but good enough to
mean we can relax about the new variant
so what we're seeing of course is it's
less likely um with this elbow infection
to result in hospitalization if you are
infected um but as balanced against that
is the fact that we're seeing that the
vaccines are very slightly less
effective both in terms of preventing
that infection in the first place and
also perhaps in preventing
hospitalization so essentially these two
things are probably going to balance out
and what we still remain concerned about
is a very fast doubling that we're
seeing of cases meaning the infection's
spreading very very rapidly and
therefore is likely to pose some
pressure on the nhs in the coming weeks
following scotland's lead wales today
announced social distancing rules from
boxing day northern ireland will order
nightclubs closed and will advise people
to reduce household mixing but the
westminster government is sticking to
plan b
for now at least
the government has issued guidance
there's been the plan b that's been
brought into place but we'll keep it
under review but the best advice to
everyone is you'll continue to remain
cautious and uh and and and keep looking
forward to christmas and as the prime
minister said no new new restrictions uh
before christmas and and beyond that we
will just keep the situation review
but not cautious enough for some richard
lost both parents and a sister to covet
19. the fact that we couldn't go into
hospital to say our goodbyes was really
heartbreaking sometimes when people do
get a bit blase about it it's
it's hurtful you know um it starts to
bring it back a little bit of you know
what can happen and you just want to
shake people and say you know get the
vaccination and get the treatment and
you know give you more chance of
surviving it
the who certainly coming as close to
criticizing england's response as united
nations diplomacy allows we have
repeatedly said um two countries not
just across europe but to put in
targeted layered approach
measures so that transmission can be
reduced we've been very clear on asking
everyone you know really to not wait to
act
huge uncertainties remain and omicron
could still be very dangerous to the nhs
but compared to what kovid 19 has thrown
us us so far evidence that this variant
looks milder is surely a cause for
cautious celebration
tom clark sky news